[Music]
on this list we are going to showcase to
y'all
the 10 biggest snakes from movies no we
won't be
including serpent-like dragons like
shenron or manda
and these are purely snakes or serpents
that have no hands or feet whatsoever
the list might surprise you it will
bring back lesser known monsters that
were quite frightening to a lot of us
while we were younger we also have put
in the big famous ones as well
and just a spoiler it won't be a kaiju
that tops this ranking
so stay till the end to find out who the
biggest of them all is
so let's get to it fam number 10 the
king cobra
the king cobra is a monster snake from
the 1999 film of the same name
it was based on an escaped genetically
engineered hybrid of an asian king cobra
and an eastern diamondback rattlesnake
it was a mutated snake that escaped from
a laboratory
and terrorizes the residence of a small
californian
brewery town it was 9.1 meters or 30
feet long
and with a giant appetite for terror
this is the official description of the
snake from the movie
personally one of my favorites as it has
mr miyagi in it
after it escapes and was set loose in
the countryside for two years
it was filled with the experimental
aggressive drug and a snake nicknamed
seth
eventually outgrows his woodland prey
and begins hunting people for food
number nine gaw this giant snake has
been portrayed differently in many of
jungle books tales and movies
originally seen in the animated movie it
was one of the antagonists that mowgli
faces when he runs away from the wolf
pack
he and sometimes she is a long-lived
serpent of a hundred years
and was seen as a sly devious python
that speaks with a soft
often entrancing tone to either lure its
victims to a weary
and dreamlike state or manipulate them
into bestowing their trust
thus allowing it to devour them
unexpectedly sometimes seen as a burmese
python
or a rock python and also as an indian
python which are three different species
it was more than 30 feet long and in its
biggest incarnation
as nearing 40 feet long in a 2018 flick
number 8 giant snake also known as the
big snake it is one of the creatures
seen in the cabin in the woods movie
the big snake appears to be a mixture of
king cobra rattle snake and anaconda or
a python
but substantially larger in proportions
around 40 feet long
it is first seen trashing around in its
cubicle
or trying to get out it is released
during the system perch during the first
wave
it wraps its body around one soldier and
the killer robot kills him while
swallowing another soldier hole all
within a matter of seconds
the snake later eats a man who is flung
over a railing
by one of the deadites catching him in
his mouth before he hits the ground
this shows that the snake was extremely
fast and agile and a monster that was
meant to be contained
number 7 anaconda the next entry to this
list is from the 2004 horror movie
anaconda the hunt for the blood orchid
and was a stand-alone sequel to the
original anaconda film
the film follows a team of researchers
set for an expedition into the southeast
asian tropical island of borneo
in indonesia to search for a sacred
flower for which they believe will bring
humans
to a longer healthier life but soon
become hunted by the deadly anacondas
inhabiting
the island these anacondas come to a
certain place in the island to mate
and it is there that the blood orchid
was found it seems that the flower gives
them
unnaturally long lives and since
anacondas grow until they die
these snakes were around 40 to 50 feet
long in size
number six the basilis also known as the
serpent of slytherin
it was a female basis that was placed by
salazar slytherin
as one of the only residents of the
chamber of secrets at hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry seen in the
movie harry potter and a chamber of
secrets
the bacillus was an extremely powerful
and dangerous beast
a horrifying monster with dark green
scales and the creature was a violent
and bloodthirsty beast of titanic size
around 50 to 60 feet long
and had deep yellow eyes she possessed
incredible strength and durability
and was resistant to many spells her
fangs were so venomous that she could
kill
any living creature that she pierced
within minutes and were capable of even
destroying horcruxes which
proved useful in defeating voldemort
later on
number five fire snakes these five
snakes appeared in the 2016 movie called
gods of egypt
they appear to be like cobras only
except much larger
and one snake appears to have black
scales while the other appears white
scale
these giant snakes are female riders on
top of them and they have the power to
spew out hot flames from their mouth
their scales seem to be hot and like
armored plates they also have teeth that
they could use to bite and attack
unlike normal snakes which only bite to
inject venom
or to help in swallowing they seem to be
over a hundred feet long in size and way
more massive than the ones on the
previous ranks
they seem to be like wingless dragons in
fact and also resembled the buraki of
the korean movie
d war in a way number four the giant boa
this giant bower is the second snake
monster to battle king kong
with the first being the giant sea
serpent from king kong escapes
the giant bow was inspired by the
serpentine elasmosaurus that battled
king kong
in the original 1933 film in the movie
king kong 1976 after king kong brought a
female back to his lair on skull island
he was suddenly attacked by an evil
looking giant boa constrictor
conned in lunch at a serpent to keep it
away from the human female
and the bower constricted itself around
kong and tried to crush him
it was later killed when kong used his
jaw breaking finishing move
the snake looked like a normal bow but
with teeth jutting out like a ravenous
predator
and it was between a hundred to two
hundred feet long
number three xiaobai jiabai was a white
snake demon seen in the movie white
snake of 2019
in her human forms jaobai appeared to be
a beautiful girl and always preferred
white dresses
however once she turned into her half
snake form
she would develop serpentine features
including scales
and a tail in her full snake form she is
a giant snake
and maybe even close to 60 meters or
easily over 200 feet long
same as the previous ranking in the
movies yao bai
had two different snake forms a normal
giant white snake at the very beginning
of the movie
and a giant white snake with
feather-like horns and spikes on her
ridges
which is a bit similar to a chinese
dragon and she battled two other giant
snake demons in the movie
number two the giant seed serpent the
giant sea serpent was included in king
kong escapes as a homage
to serpent-like elasmosaurus gong
battles in the original 1933 film
the giant sea serpent only has a short
appearance in the film king kong escapes
when the film central character susan
watson and her companions are attempting
to leave mondo island
the giant sea snake serpent rises out
from the water and approaches their
craft
the giant sea serpent was confronted by
king kong when it approached the
hovercraft
as it made its way into the explorer the
serpent constricted its body around kong
but later on the giant ape was able to
triumph when he chewed
and defeated the serpent aside into the
water it was stated to be 85 meters long
or 278 feet
and number one the emoji the emoji is a
legendary old serpent which is born
every few millennium
their history goes back to the ancient
times when the world was beginning to
form
and colossal prehistoric creatures
roamed the earth as the very first
of the lineage of colossal serpents the
emoji were
revered to as gods however they rarely
ever surfaced and
instead chose to live in their own realm
in the movie d war
two emojis are seen fighting over to get
a yuji
it is said that every 500 years in
return for kindness that animoogie
provided to humanity the emoji would be
bestowed a yugi
a which is a source of untold power that
would transform it into a celestial
dragon
these movies are gigantic in size at 200
meters long
or 656 feet and they are the biggest
snakes seen
ever seen in movies and so with that we
come to the end of the list
so do hit your woman i mean do hit the
like button
and also the subscribe button and smash
your woman i mean smash that
notification bell for regular
updates on future videos